FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for the Developer Show.
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
And P Beta 3 is now available.
It's our next milestone in
this year's Android P Developer
Preview.
And it takes us
very close to what
you'll see in the final
version of Android P, due
later this summer.
Included are the
Beta 3 system images
for Pixel devices and
the Android Emulator,
as well as an update to the
Android Studio Build Tools
to include D8 as an
independent tool.
Head on over to the post to get
started in a few simple steps.
And to learn what's new
for text in Android P,
check out this post.
TextView is one of the
most critical components
of the Android View system.
So this is why we
continue to invest
in both developer- and
user-facing features
and improvements, including
precomputed text, magnifier,
Smart Linkify, and more.
Now that the core
has been stabilized
with the recent Kubernetes
1.11 release, we'd
like to share a deeper
look at the Kubernetes work
that Google is driving, as
well as some of the innovation
we've built on
Kubernetes foundations
in the last three months.
Check out the post for details
on priority and preemption,
changes to CRDs, Cloud
Provider plugins, and more.
And if you missed any of the
Google Cloud Platform updates
from June, check out this post.
Highlights include Node.js
on Google App Engine's
standard environment,
QUIC, a transfer protocol
optimized for HTTPS, and Cloud
Firestore as a GCP storage
option.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: OK.
That's [? coming. ?]